"When I was a child my brother would tell
me a bedtime story
about the man who murdered our Father,
and all the things we would do to that man."
"You never should have trusted Cersei" "You never should have either"
"Death has many faces and I look forward to seeing this one"
"How long do we have?"
"Before the Sun comes up tomorrow."
Hey guys, Pete here. this will be my Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 2 trailer
breakdown. this will obviously contain
spoilers if you haven't watched episode
1 of season 8 yet so make sure you do
that before you watch this video I'm
gonna break the new trailer down
scene-by-scene and please make sure you
subscribe to my channel so that you can
watch my Game of Thrones season 8
episode 1 recap and review video that
will be coming out right after this the
episode 2 trailer opens with the
Daenerys voiceover we'll see that she's
talking to Jamie Lannister who arrived
at the end of the last episode we hear
and then see her say when I was a child
my brother would tell me a bedtime story
about the man who killed our Father and
all the things we would do to that man
of course you remember her brother
Viserys from the first season and you
have an idea of what those stories might
be miss James got kind of a shocked look
or a worried look on his face and we see
that this is all happening in the Great
Hall of Winterfell with everyone around
to see it we see bran we see Sansa we
see everyone sitting in the hall of
course Jamie Lannister the Kingslayer
got that name by killing Daenerys his
father King Aerys the second this makes
for an interesting opening of the
trailer we know that Jaime killed the
Mad King for the right reason
Aerys was losing his mind and wanted to
burn everyone with wildfire it's made up
who he is
he got labeled as a dishonourable
Kingslayer when what he did actually
took a lot of courage the scene comes
off as tense in the trailer how it's
framed but I doubt there will be much
actual drama related to this I think
Dany has to confront the man who killed
her father who she never knew by the way
Jaime needs to explain himself and what
happened in front of everyone and then
life will have to move on to face the
threat of the White Walkers who we see
are fast approaching later on in this
episode - trailer after the Jaime scene
it cuts and it says they're on the next
Game of Thrones in the little transition
it's kind of interesting because
sometimes they do trailers that show
multiple episodes
the future that makes it seem like it's
probably just from the next episode what
we see here and since we saw that pre
battle footage like some of the stuff
that I'll talk about later I thought
maybe it was a little bit of episode 2
in episode 3 next we see Tyrion looking
tense with Jorah and Varys behind him we
see Daenerys walk by them and head into
the Winterfell library to talk with
Sansa we hear say you never should have
trusted Cersei to which Sansa replies
you never should have either we see
Sansa is wearing her breastplate outfit
and that they are being pretty formal
but not necessarily hostile since Jaime
has arrived he would have explained that
Cersei double-crossed them which is what
Sansa would be talking about here
there's not a lot more that we can glean
from this short transitional scene here
though we do see another shot of
Daenerys looking at songs at the table
in the Great Hall that is unrelated to
this library meeting and it looks like
they're trying to play up the tension
between these two characters but as I
mentioned with Jaime and that drama it
doesn't appear that there's gonna be too
much time for them to actually fight or
squabble or whatever you want to call it
it seems like it's going to be a point
of telling the story but it's gonna have
to get moved along after that we get a
quick shot of northern looking soldiers
moving outside the Winterfell walls
I say northern looking because you can't
make out much besides the helmets
they're wearing which at least on the
first man looks like the stark Helms
we've seen in the past I brightened it
and zoomed in me because at first glance
I thought maybe the guy in black on the
side there was dollar or said but it
doesn't look like it when I look closer
in that process there wasn't anything
extra I can make out you know there's no
sigils or anything that stand out so
we'll just leave it at that their
northern looking soldier we do have
Arya's voice over here she says death
it's got many faces I look forward to
seeing this one this is the same as the
first season a trailer while she is
saying that we see that image of the
forge where they're preparing
dragonglass weapons we've seen that one
before we get a new look at Jorah
pre-battle looking at hearts pain this
means there there must be a scene
in Episode two where Sam gives him how
star Lee's Valyrian steel sword we saw
it on his hip in the trailer so we knew
that was gonna happen
but this just puts it in context we're
gonna see a scene between those two
where he gives him the sword this is
followed by Daenerys approaching John
and the crypts this is a scene we've
seen in previous trailers but now we
know that John is aware of his parentage
we didn't really know what was going on
with these two we still don't but we
know at least John knows who his parents
are at this point it looks as though
Daenerys is coming to him so now the
question is if she already knows about
his parentage and is she coming to
comfort him or is she there because he's
been acting weird since he found out
about it and she's coming to find out
what's going on with him it's a little
bit weird that this is in there while
Arya is talking about death but I'm not
reading too much into that what I do see
and what I think it is safe to say is
that when these two come out of the
crypts in this little sequence here that
the idea that John is a Targaryen and
Daenerys his nephew will be known if it
wasn't before that some people think
that John might try to lie about this to
not upset things when you know not upset
the applecart or whatever you want to
say but for to me in my opinion it looks
like they both will probably know at the
end of this talk in the crib there's
another new shot of Arya who is shooting
a bow and arrow this appears to be in
the period of time leading up to the
battle rather than in the battle itself
it makes it seem more likely to me that
it means that that was are his hand that
we'd seen there was a lot of speculation
at whose hand that was up on the walls
during the battle with a bow I mean it
could be that she's practicing with
someone else maybe like Lyanna Mormont
or someone else it looks like a woman's
hand a female hand and perhaps this is
letting us know that that is actually
Arya I mean we've seen Arya fight and
train with swords obviously needle with
daggers staffs at the time of the house
of undying we haven't really seen a
train with a bow and arrow since the
beginning of the series from there we
cut to John asking torment how long do
we have this is odd because we know
torment was that last hearth after the
night King
Ned umber their HBO has confirmed that
that it was the last hearth not really
sure how torment and his riders would
manage to get around and beat the night
Kings army to Winterfell they may try to
explain that in a way the show like
maybe the night Kings moving around he's
not going in a straight line but it may
be an indication that there's gonna be
some crazy moving around on the map kind
of stuff that we've gotten used to over
the last couple seasons but either way
they beat him there and they're gonna be
able to warn John and everyone else how
close they actually are before torment
answers John we get a blast of images
like they like to do in the trailers we
see outside the gate at Winterfell where
there are Dothraki riding around and we
see unsullied filing out through the
gate it looks like John is riding on a
horse but it's not really possible to
tell if all these things are related
like are the Dothraki just moving around
and the insulator just moving around and
John happens to be exiting at that same
time are they going somewhere it doesn't
really look like it but it's possible
then we see it cut to the testing of a
trebuchet this was a question before the
season because some of these were
spotted on the Winterfell set like in
set photos that people had taken but we
can see here that this is outside and
they are going to use it as a defensive
weapon against the approaching army
rather than like a human army being
outside the wall attacking Winterfell I
say human because it doesn't seem likely
that the night king would be using
trebuchet so there was some speculation
that maybe Cersei might try to attack
because of these seeds weapons like she
would come before like she wouldn't wait
for them to come south she would come
north herself but what we see is that
they have them as defensive weapons they
could definitely use them they could use
fire projectiles and use that against
the army of the whites which seems like
a pretty good idea to me then we have a
dark image of the battlements of
Winterfell like from behind when you
brighten it up you can see that John is
there
that there are troops outside in front
of the walls my guess is that this is
the unsullied and Dothraki since we've
seen them in the trailers and it looks
like this is pre battle as they're in
formation like there's not a battle
going on out there there's just a bunch
of soldiers again you don't expect that
the night's king army would be like kind
of just roll up and hang out like it
would be a straight rush you know the
mean of them attacking to me it looks
like this is sort of a Night's Watch
throwback kind of thing like the people
next to him look like Ed and Sam if you
go off the hair I can't you can't see
anything else and they're wearing big
winter cloak so if I had to guess I
would say that this is John Edie and Sam
looking out as they're waiting for the
night's king army to approach after that
we see a sequence of clips that were in
previous trailers already we see Jorah
riding out and getting into position we
see grey worm in the sand a and their
kiss goodbye that happens inside the
walls before they go out into the field
then we see Daenerys in her quarters
with that dressed look on her face we
know that jor is there in the shadows he
comes out in a different clip that we
saw and this is most likely him
discussing the fact of who John's
parents are with her in what that means
after that we see a shot of John who
looks surprised in the yard of
Winterfell before it fades to black this
is one of the most interesting little
shots I think this in REO with the bow
this could be torment like when torment
arrives but he looks John actually looks
shook like something happened and I
can't really say for sure
what's going on here after that it faced
the black and we hear torment say before
the Sun comes up tomorrow meaning that
the army of the Dead will be arriving
that night and the trailer ends with
Tyrion looking out from the top of the
walls alone it's a little bit strange
that he's there by himself but it's a
nice looking image to set the mood for
what we know is coming in episode 3 so a
lot of recycled footage from previous
trailers but also a lot of new shots it
sort of looks like the end of the
episode will be set up as a cliffhanger
for the battle as we'll see everyone get
ready and
then if all this footage is from the
second episode it'll end right there
like perhaps that shot we saw from the
trailer where we see one of the white
walkers horses arrived maybe that'll be
the final scene of episode 2 it's
interesting that torments the only
person that we see arrived since we know
Theon is on his way and assume that
Melisandre should be on her way too I
think it's very possible that Theon
would make it before the battle starts
so they probably just chose not to show
that yeah the timing is a bit
questionable with that like can you get
there that fast but it just makes more
sense for him to be there when it starts
rather than him show up he's not like
coming with some huge army or anything
so I don't know Melisandre and the other
hand could go either way if she shows up
beforehand then there have to be some
story time invested in her explaining to
John and Davos why they should let her
fight why they shouldn't kill her let
her fight the night king because that's
what they want to do when they see her
next you know it was a promise that was
made I'm not against that happening but
there just isn't any indication of that
going down here unless that shot we saw
of John where he looked shocked if that
was maybe her arriving with a bunch of
people or something that could make
sense but the fact that we haven't seen
her yet might mean instead that she'll
show up during the battle when it's
already underway and especially if she
brings people with her that could help
tip the balance of things I mean she
should be playing a big part anyways
with magic but you know she brings more
troops that could be an actual
interesting entrance that would be a
nice surprise during the course of the
battle as far as what we do see I don't
think there are a lot of surprises here
we need to move things along to get the
stage set for the battle I think a lot
of people expected that Jaime might
bring some troops with him and that this
might have smooth things over
but either way we all know that he will
end up fighting alongside John and Danes
forces when we've seen it in the clips
already as mentioned in the beginning
they do have to do their thing I mean
they have to air out their grievances
but eventually they're going to accept
his pledge one thing we don't see here
is the Jaime and Brienne reunion which
I'm sure
we'll be a memorable part of episode two
another thing we don't see here is any
kings landing footage at all and we
don't see the scene where John and
Daenerys were and ragged stone from the
previous trailer I don't think this
rules out that we won't see any King's
Landing in this episode but it does feel
less likely and it was already unlikely
that we would see John and Daenerys
leave Winterfell before the battle in
fact based on what we see it seems like
this will be a somewhat unsurprising
episode overall I think it'll be
interesting to see how they handle the
preparations and what if anything we
learn from torment and his journey from
the last hearts about what's going on
with the night king and his forces since
bran can skin change ravens and possibly
see future events in visions although we
should keep in mind that if he does see
things about the future they'll probably
be symbolic because that's what
everyone's visions of the future usually
look like but coupled with the fact that
torment Adam beric are traveling and
they're gonna make it there before the
night's king and they have seen what
happened at the last hearth it should
start to dawn on everyone at Winterfell
how dire their situation actually is if
you really think about it they don't
have much of a chance against the undead
army which is growing as it moves so
they have to put a plan in place if they
want to have a chance of defeating them
sure they have two dragons and the night
king only has one but I mean I think it
should be kept in mind that everyone who
dies on the side of the Living can be
raised to be on the other side all the
preparation in the world as far as
fortifying the walls and the castle and
lining up the troops and everything else
like it's still way in the favor of the
night king in the White Walkers so
they're gonna have to put a plan in
place if they want to have a chance of
winning so like this could definitely
make for a good episode of Game of
Thrones these are things that they
wouldn't likely give away in the trailer
since they may involve Brandon looking
into the past to get a better idea of
what they can do to stop the night king
there will definitely be all this stuff
we've seen here but there may also be
some big reveals in the lead-up to the
battle I think we will get resolution to
the Jamie problem imagine Brianne will
say her first words of season 8 in order
to explaining that he is a changed man I
think the Sun centenares tension will be
there I don't think it's gonna disappear
but I think that Sansa is really just a
representation of what everyone in the
North would think about Danni and her
army coming there like people like to
get down on Sansa and say oh there's
gonna be all this drama but she's just
really a representative of like he saw
the people's faces as they were
approaching in the first episode nobody
was excited to see this at least for the
battle they're gonna come around because
that's the most important thing that
they have to deal with and basically you
know John bending the knee was the right
thing to do based on what he knew was
going to happen so I think it looks like
Danny and John will at least confront
his parentage and the fact that he has a
better claim for the throne I thought it
was interesting that Sam made it clear
that he felt John should press his claim
obviously that's related to what
happened to his family but it still is
also just a representation of what
pretty much everyone else will think
everyone else except Daenerys that it so
I think they'll have to talk about that
I'm not sure if there's going to be a
resolution to that before the battle
begins but the seed will be planted and
it'll be interesting to see how they
think about that how they sort through
that and what they end up deciding to do
the getting prepared part of the episode
is the most interesting thing in my mind
as I said they can't really beat the
night King straight up this leads some
people to think that they will actually
lose the Battle of Winterfell
they'll have to flee we know there's
tunnels below the castle we know the
crypts have a lot of foreshadowing
surrounding them that's definitely gonna
play a part it's a reasonable idea to
think that they'll lose here but the
thing that really makes this hard to
imagine for me is that if the White
Walkers move south they're gonna destroy
a massive path through Winterfell on
'we imagine how big the army the dead
would be by the time they reached King's
Landing if they did go there and the
next confrontation happens there I'm not
saying that it won't happen I mean it
seems pretty clear that there will be a
second battle in the south but I'm just
not sure if it's against the white
walkers or against Cersei by herself
that is what I find the most interesting
though is how they're gonna prepare for
this how they're going to get ready what
their plan will be I have some ideas of
what that might be but I don't know that
we see anything related to any of it
here we only get a quick shot of brand
for a second in the Great Hall we see
aria with the bow and arrow which
doesn't have much to do with anything so
outside of that shot of John looking
really shocked it's pretty
straightforward what we see here but I
am excited I thought the first episode
was a little bit rushed but it was also
quite good for what it had to do I'm
interested in how they make this a
really compelling episode when they laid
it out that the battle is gonna happen
in the very next episode and everyone
has their attention kind of on that and
I'm curious as to what they're holding
back so let me know what you guys think
do you think that Theon will arrive do
you think that Melisandre will arrive do
you think we'll get anything going on in
King's Landing that we didn't see here
how do you think things are gonna turn
out between John and Daenerys how do you
think those conversations are gonna go
how do you think torment and beric and
dollar said managed to go around the
night King and his army do you think
there's something else going on there
that we don't see and do you think it
will end as the big cliffhanger as the
battle is getting ready to begin let me
know in the comments what you think what
you're hoping to see what you want to
see what you don't want to see please
like the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe if you're not a subscriber
already I already started work on my
episode 1 recap and review so that'll be
coming out shortly
I appreciate you taking the time to
watch the video and I will be talking to
you soon